Okay, now that we have seen how register renaming works, let's try it ourselves.
So let's have a register renaming quiz. Okay so
we will have a RAT here that will tell us where the values for R1, R2,
R3, R4, R5, and R6 are. And over here we will have a sequence of instructions as
they're fetched. And then we will need to write in what's renamed. Okay. So
here we have the initial state of the RAT which is simply R1 is mapped to P1,
R2 to P2, etc. And here are our instructions. In order to help you get started,
I'm going to rename the first instruction. So after renaming,
it's still a multiplication. R2 and R2 are P2 and
P2. R2 is where we should put our value and, remember,
we need to rename it in the RAT, so it's going to be in P7.
So this is what this rename instruction looks like. Read the registers.
Physical registers P2 and P2, and put the result in P7. Now it's your turn.
You need to both tell me what's renamed and also update the RAT accordingly.